[Music]
although I indulged in every manner of
folly and nonsense in my lifetime Heaven
seems not to have punished me as yet
here I am 42 sound of health and without
a scratch on my body some of my friends
were beaten to death others vanished
Without a Trace or suffered one fate or
another I must have been born under a
lucky star the way I did whatever I
pleased no other Samurai was such a low
stipend spent money as I did and how I
blustered and swaggered around with a
trail of followers at my beck and call
iwalker monos of imported silk and Fine
Fabrics that were beyond the reach of
most people I ate my fill of good food
and all my life I bought as many
prostitutes as I liked
I lived life fully
only recently have I come to my senses
and begun to act more like a human being
I have no learning to speak of having
taught myself to write only in my
twenties and barely enough to cover my
own needs at that my friends were all
bad and none good unable to distinguish
between right and wrong I took my
excesses as the behavior of Heroes and
brave men in everything I was misguided
and I will never know how much anguish I
caused my relatives parents wife and
children even more reprehensible I
behaved most disloyally to my Lord and
Master the Shogun and without uttermost
Defiance to my superiors
thus did I finally bring myself to this
Lower State
when I think of my past my hair stands
on end
he who would call himself a man would do
well not to imitate my ways
[Music]
gambaru is a Japanese phrase that means
to work hard and slog on through tough
times and though the ability to
persevere and power through is admirable
sometimes it's a good idea to take a
break and reflect this video is a paid
partnership with better help and they
are the world's largest therapy service
with better help you can instantly tap
into a network of over 30 000 licensed
and experienced therapists who can help
you with a wide range of issues with
you've been focused on gambaru or not it
is great for our busy lives you can
schedule live sessions when it's
convenient for you and if your therapist
isn't the right fit for any reason you
can switch to a new therapist at no
additional charge with better help you
get the same professionalism and quality
you expect from in-office therapy and at
a more affordable price so get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
forward slash voices of the past and
I've also linked them Below in the
description thanks to betterhelp for
supporting history content on YouTube
foreign
there can't be many in the world as
foolish as I am I was the child of my
father's concubine she fell out of favor
with him and I was taken in by my
father's wife I think of her as my real
mother and put under the care of a wet
nurse I was naughty from the time I was
little and made life difficult for my
mother and with my father away at his
office every day I acted up and was so
headstrong that all of their wits end
we lived in the aborah hurry section of
fukugawa in the garden there was an
ornamental Pond that was filled with
water drawn from one of the nearby
canals during the summer I would swim in
it every day
my mother suffered from palsy and had
trouble getting around the rest of the
household was also female I looked down
on all of them and spent my days getting
into one kind of Mischief or another
when I was five I took part in a kite
fight against rokichi the son of a
laborer in May Cho chokichi who was
older by about three years seized my
kite smashed it and took away the string
I picked up a jagged Rock and grabbing
hold of the collar of his kimono hit him
in the face blood came spurting out of
his mangled lips and trochichi began
bawling my father happened to see this
from Over the Garden fence he sent one
of his men to fetch me home what do you
mean he said angrily hurting someone's
child like that you can't be left
unpunished he tied me to one of the
posts in the veranda and whacked me on
the head with a wooden clog to this day
I have a bald spot and a dent where he
struck me the razor gets caught and
nicks the skin whenever I have my head
shaved and each time I'm reminded of
that chokichi
[Music]
I was adopted by the katsu family when I
was seven my age was officially given a
17 and the hair at the front of my head
was cut off accordingly as part of the
adoption procedure Ishikawa Ukon no
Shogun the commissioner of my unit and
his assistant Obi daishachiro came to
the house how old are you and what is
your name ishikoa asked man is kokichi
and I'm 17. Ishikawa pretended to be
taken aback well for 17 you certainly
look old he burst out laughing
I got into another fight over a kite
again with some boys from maicho there
must have been 20 or 30 of them I took
them on alone hitting and punching but
they finally got the better of me my
hair had fallen loose all over my face
and I was sobbing I took out my short
sword and slashed left and right but I
knew I was beaten and decided then and
there to commit Harry Kiri I stripped to
the waist and sat down on the rock as it
so happened a rice dealer by the name of
shirakoya was standing nearby he talked
me into giving up the idea and took me
home
after this though all the boys in the
neighborhood became my followers
I was seven at the time
[Music]
when I was nine my father took me to
take Judo lessons with Suzuki sebei a
relative of the katsu family in
yokoamicho I behaved myself at first but
soon got into Mischief my fellow
students strongly disliked me and ganged
up against me all the time
on the day that an all-night mid-winter
session was to be held we received
permission from the teacher to bring
food we took a break at midnight I
packed a lacquer box full of bean Jam
cakes and had been looking forward all
day to this moment when we would share
the food but my classmates had other
plans they got together and tied me up
with an obey hoisted me to one of the
rafters and began eating even helping
themselves to the cakes so I pissed on
their heads spraying the food that had
been spread out and naturally everything
had to be thrown away serve them right
too
when I was 11 I became a student of
udono jinzemon a swordmaster in store
godai I like the fact that udono
exclusively taught the technique for the
wooden sword and I practiced diligently
the son of Ishikawa ukan no Shogun my
commissioner was also in my class he
knew all about me how much my stipend
was and so forth and taunted me in front
of the other students at every
opportunity katso what's your stipend a
measly 40 bales of rice hahaha
since he was the commissioner's son I
kept quiet
but he continued to make fun of me so
one day I hit him good and hard with my
wooden sword cursed him out and left him
blubbering
when I was 12 my brother hiko Shiro
arranged for me to begin school he took
me to the shogunate academy in yoshima I
began by studying the Chinese classic
the greater learning at most I learned
to read about five or six pages of the
greater learning the two teachers soon
sent word that they didn't want me which
suited me just fine
and so I did nothing but ride and with
my money all gone I began stealing from
my mother's money and the cash she had
set aside for emergencies my brother was
away in shinano at the time on a
five-year assignment as District
administrator when he heard that I was
spending all my time and money on riding
he ordered me to give up lessons and
sent a letter to my teacher giving
notice he also scolded me severely and
told me to stay at home for a while I
couldn't leave the house
and what a pain that was
[Music]
I was 14 I made up my mind to run away
to the Kyoto area and stay there for the
rest of my life after all I thought no
matter what a man puts his hand to he'll
always be able to eat
on the 28th day of the fifth month I put
on a pair of trousers over my kimono and
set off I didn't know a thing about the
world and as for money I had only the
seven or eight gold Ryu I'd stolen and
tucked in the band I wrapped around my
stomach
asking directions along the way I got as
far as shinagawa I was lonely and
frightened but I pressed on and stayed
the night at an inn in fujisawa the next
morning I woke up and walked around
aimlessly wondering what to do
two Tradesmen caught up with me where
are you heading they asked no in
particular I said maybe some place near
Kyoto come along with us we're going
that way too
taking heart I went with them to odawara
that night at the Inn they said tomorrow
we'll be passing through the barrier
station at hakone have you got a travel
permit I never heard of such a thing
give us 200 coppers and we'll get one
for you
I did as they said and was let through
the barrier station the next day all
along I remained on my guard but by the
time we stopped at hamamatsu for the
night I felt I could trust them since
they'd taken such good care of me
so before going to sleep I took off all
my clothes
[Music]
in the morning however when I woke up
and looked at my pillow I saw that
everything was gone during the night
they had stolen my kimono my pair of
swords and the stomach band containing
my money I was stunned I asked The
Innkeeper if he had seen the two men he
said oh they said they were going on
ahead to be in time for a festival at
tsushima Shrine in owari and that you
were to catch up completely overcome I
burst into tears the kind Innkeeper
tried to console me you know what they
were flies on sesame seeds thieves the
play on Travelers and here I thought
they were your companions from Edo what
a shame
where will you go now I'm not sure I was
thinking of going somewhere near Kyoto
yes but what can you do with only an
underobe to your name The Innkeeper was
at a loss too but then he disappeared
for a minute and returned with a big
Ladle well he said you're not the only
one from Edo who's been robbed on this
road here take this and go to the
neighborhood of hamamatsu Castle and see
if you can't beg for a coin or two
I got up my courage and spent the whole
day begging
by evening I'd received about a peck of
rice and wheat and 120 or 130 copper
pennies The Innkeeper was a good-hearted
man and put me out for the night the
following day he said it might not be a
bad idea if you first went to issei
Shrine and prayed for your well-being
I gave him half of the Grain and 50
coppers as a token of my gratitude and
headed for ese
during the day I begged for arms and
after dark I sought shelter in Pine
Groves on Riverbanks and in roadside
shrines swarms of mosquitoes prevented
me from sleeping and believe me that was
no fun
one night I slept by a big pile of rocks
just inside the entrance to a riding
ground near future Castle the riding
ground boarded on a bamboo Grove and
beyond that stood a temple with the
shogun's crest on its main gate
early in the morning I was awakened by
14 or 15 Samurai who had come to
practice riding they galloped around
with an air of fierce determination but
I could tell right away that none of
them was any good as I got up a couple
of the stable boys spotted me and began
shouting look a beggar boy the nerve of
him sleeping here I mumbled some excuses
and stayed where I was squatting on my
heels but the men were so hopelessly
clumsy they couldn't help laughing out
loud the stable boys were indignant they
sat on me with their fists and after
knocking me down dragged me out of the
riding ground
Samurai who was about 40 came over hey
you bigger boy who said how does a kid
like you criticize Samurai for the way
they ride where are you from anyway come
on speak up I'm from Edo and I'll have
you know I wasn't always a beggar do you
like horses well let's see you ride then
clad only in my underobe I showed them a
thing or two about riding everyone was
impressed and said to one another this
wretch must be the son of a samurai the
samurai who had spoken to me earlier
said come home with me and I'll give you
a meal
foreign so after the practice ended I
followed him to his home he was on a
side street near the residence of the
future Town magistrate he told me to
wait and soon came out with a tray piled
high with rice and soup it was delicious
he came to the kitchen afterwards and
asked me my name and who my parents were
when I put him off with some lies he
said I really feel sorry for you stay
with us he gave me a kimono and had his
wife arrange my hair and fill a bucket
with hot water for me to wash up with
the two just couldn't get enough of me
that night he called me into the living
room and questioned me once more about
my background
I lied again I stayed for six or seven
days and the entire time the Samurai and
his wife looked after me as though I was
their own child
I had different plans however what good
was it making do in a house like this
when I could just as well go to Kyoto
and become a retainer in some Noble
man's house
and so one evening I changed into my old
underrobe and after folding my kimono
Adobe neatly by the quilts I slipped out
of the house I got up Before Sunrise and
I ran as fast as I could towards Kyoto
I wandered for several days begging and
at yokaiichi bumped into Morata a beggar
I knew we bought food and stretched out
on the floor of a Pine Grove
we talked of all that had happened since
we'd last seen each other and spent the
night side by side on a bed of pine
needles
you've got to admit the friendship
between Beggars is something special
I wandered listlessly for several days
one night I've forgotten where I lay
down near a cliff and somehow fell off
the edge in my sleep I must have passed
out too when I regained Consciousness
the next morning I realized I had hit my
testicles against sharp rock it was too
painful to walk I got better little by
little and by the third day was able to
walk around gingerly by the time I
reached hakone however my testicles had
become swollen and were beginning to
ooze pass
it had been four months since I'd run
away and here I was a samurai wasting my
time on things that would never lead to
anything I made up my mind to return to
Edo and face whatever punishment my
father had in store
[Music]
everyone was excited kokichis come back
kokichi's come back I went to my room
and slept for 10 days straight
I was told that in my absence the family
had offered up all kinds of prayers and
incantations and it even sent a cousin a
nun called kaizan all the way to Kyoto
to look for me
a doctor was sent for after examining me
he said now is there something you want
to tell me about yourself below the
waist
tentacles were still in bad shape but I
stubbornly denied any trouble within
three months however they had become so
infected that I could no longer move
about I had to stay at home for the next
two years
my father reported my return to the
commissioner Ishikawa ukan no shogen it
is indeed a shameful turn of events my
father said I will seat with the kokichi
retires and that someone is adopted to
replace him as head of the katso family
but Ishikawa disagreed if kokichi hadn't
returned by the end of the month I would
have taken measures to end the family
line but he's come back but all's well
that ends well leave him be by the time
he's older he will no doubt have mended
his ways and will be able to perform
some useful service
for now take good care of him
all concerned were mightily relieved I
was told
foreign
[Music]
and made the rounds of the powers that
be I went to the commissioner's home in
akasaka koichigai Soto and begged him to
recommend me for a post I even submitted
a list of the misdeeds I had committed
adding a request that I be considered
now that I had repented an agent came
from his office one day he said be
forewarned that we will be sending out
investigators to gather information on
you
I waited expectantly the commissioner
spoke to me one morning
your followers simply refused to tell on
you and though you've confessed
everything we find upon investigating
that the Mischief you've done is far
more serious than you say
be that as it may you have repented and
that's good enough for me I will do my
best to get you on appointment continue
to report diligently
[Music]
showed up at his residence with renewed
further and practiced fencing in my
spare time often enough my name was
entered onto the rules of candidates but
not once was I given a post and that I
found very galling and was anxious to
find official employment but I also had
to dash around making money then my
father died and I lost heart completely
his death was entirely unexpected it
seems he'd had a stroke I was giving
fencing lessons at mazuki Inari Shrine
when one of his young retainers came
running with the news her race to my
father's place but it was too late
stayed on helping out and left the
following morning
the next few days were taken up with my
father's affairs
my own son was then five I went back to
my business as soon as the morning
period of 49 days was completed
it then seemed like a good idea to form
a sword Association in which members
would pay dues and take turns buying a
sword I invited my fellow Swordsmen and
friends to join along with hosokawa
Chikara masayoshi minobi taike nautane
Kobayashi shinpei and all the other
sword appraisers in business one day I
went to the shogunate prison in senju
and tested my sword on the corpses of
criminals who had been executed after
that I became a student of asuemon and
learned how to Lop off the heads of
corpses with a single stroke
my new landlord okano magoichiro was a
rake and a spendthrift he owed 17 Rio to
a tea house in the yoshiwara and unable
to pay was being threatened with a
lawsuit he came to see me I just moved
in and in my ignorance got together some
cash for him but okano got into debt
again having obtained 70 Rio with 5
interest a month to buy a prostitute out
of her contract
the trouble was a security he had handed
Over The Ledger recording the payment of
rice taxes by his thiefs the retainers
at home and on his thiefs came to me for
advice I got back the document by
putting up a security swords and other
Goods my landlord however made no move
to help me get my goods back
I eventually retrieved them one by one
but from then on I was always
hard-pressed for cash and with all my
social obligations it was an awful
nuisance
for a while I managed to survive by
selling what I had left but they soon
ran out of goods and was forced to sell
my own possessions I hated parting with
them I'd collected them painstakingly
over the years what else was I to do I
sold off every single item and at half
the original cost
I went back immediately to my sword
business every night I went to the
second-hand Goods Market in Kanda and
hondro and being a pretty sharp
bargainer I soon set aside a tidy sum
many of the friends I'd helped in times
of trouble came to me when they had
swords to sell but since they were not
knowledgeable about swords I never made
a loss
[Music]
one day at son of suchia I got into a
big fight with Kumar the son of an
employee the copper mint in hashiba we
were on the second floor so I picked up
Kuma and threw him down the stairs he
had to be carried home by some man who
came running from the mint but a while
later about 30 men appeared with hooked
Spears they began surrounding the house
I flung off my outer garments hitched up
the Hem of my kimono and rushed outside
swinging My Sword I forced the men to
retreat two or three hundred yards but
just then a band of men arrived from the
local patrol office to break up the
fight after this even the Crohn's and
shrews who were hired to escort
customers to the brothels Drew away as
soon as they saw me
[Music]
foreign
schools of other Adventures but they
took place so long ago have all but
forgotten them
both of my older brothers kept a close
watch on me I couldn't care less and
past my days carousing to my heart's
content for the last three or four years
I had fallen into dissolute ways and had
been spending most of my time in the
yoshiwara
so much so that the Roughnecks who
prowled through the quarters at the
Comey underlings and no one dared defy
me
naturally this took huge amounts of
money but I was determined not to fall
into debt and so I hustled every night
at the markets
One Night in the summer I was summoned
to hiko Shiro's house in kamizawa Cho
and my brother's house everyone was in
tears his wife took me to shintaro's
room and said kokichi why do you persist
in Behaving so recklessly your brother
has made inquiries about you here and
there and worried that you might do
something truly Dreadful so he's decided
to lock you up in a cage shintaro and
the rest of us tried to talk him out of
it but he wouldn't listen the cage was
finished yesterday it's in the garden
who went out to the Garden the cage was
steadily built with double enclosures I
said to shintaru and my sister-in-law I
appreciate my brother's concern I've
already made up my mind to stay in the
cage for good and not to come out even
if I'm forgiven you see around where I
live in honzo I'm well known and
regarded as a hero of sorts but after a
humiliation like this I could never show
my face to my fellow man I will Fast and
die as soon as possible
my sister-in-law pleaded with me how did
things have come to this please turn
over a new Leaf what sense would there
be if I did ever since my father died
I've had no one to turn to and as for
any hope of obtaining office I gave that
up a long time ago I decided I might as
well do what I want and die
I really think it would be better if I
went in the cage couldn't you at least
go home and talk it over with your wife
that won't be necessary as I said I'm
not at all worried about my family
rentaro is 16. he'd be better off if I
was dead if I lived too long I'd only be
a nuisance my sister-in-law insisted
that I go home for the time being
I went home and waited at eight I had
still received no word so I took off for
the yoshiwara and stayed for the night
shintaro urged me to write a letter of
apology to my brother he'll have to be
appeased one way or another
I couldn't be bothered then I heard that
my sister-in-law worried sick was going
from Temple to Temple asking for prayers
on my behalf I decided to put her mind
at rest once and for all
the following spring I passed on the
family headship to rintaro
I was 37. my past conduct truly fills me
with horror I am most fortunate in
having a filial and obedient son my
daughter's two are very devoted my wife
has never gone against my wishes
I am altogether satisfied to have lived
until now without any serious mishap
42 I have understood for the first time
what it means to follow in the path of
righteousness to serve one's Lord and
one's father to live with one's Kinsmen
in Harmony and to have compassion and
love for one's wife children and
servants that my children their children
and their children's children read this
record carefully
Savor its meaning
so be it
[Music]